[Music]
um
here's some poetic justice
charges have been dropped as an
ex-teacher marries a student she was
accused of having sex with hmm
she was accused of having sex with i
have to ask a question please ask the
question is she hot
i have to show you the photo for you to
judge yourself do you guys remember the
forgiveness
one in utah letourneau the filipino kid
she's so hot bro that was a razor so hot
so hot but that's her mug shot though
right that's her mug shot there's no
potential oh you want to see the
yearbook photo because i bet you like
you know take her to sephora
and you know take her to support you got
to start off at the makeup hey for how
long i gotta take her to sephora
[Laughter]
take her to 24 hour fitness while you're
at it how many visits do i have who
looks hot in their mug shot except that
one guy with the that one black guy with
the green eyes that's a really good oh
yeah yeah he got a modeling career she
was in jail probably for a while right
before she got released you said uh well
no no it was more that uh the charges
were dropped
i thought lindsay lohan
still had it together in a mug shot just
just so you know just to just do a post
but she was a little teary her mascara
was running a little i kind of like that
oh you like that i'm kind of [ __ ] up
like that
it's the post choking face i really like
it i really enjoy that you know a lot
it's true so a former teacher in the us
who was accused of having sex with a
student has now married the student and
the charges against her have been
dropped because they're married that's
all i have to do
because it's true love i guess it is it
is was charged in february 2019 with
having sexual contact with one of her
male students at sarkozy high school in
missouri misery missouri
age of consent probably 13 in missouri
yeah how old is this full rock bro it
was high school so i had to be anywhere
from 14 18. oh now this guy's 18 and
they're together would that be
considered a high school sweetheart
i believe it would be
that's a good question
i think that's fair yeah i think so
that's a good one oh we're high school
sweethearts
oh cool unfortunately we don't have any
doctors on the show so we can't answer
the question it's a great question high
school sweet the first one that blew up
was lieterno yeah that dude was 12. that
was 12. he was like filipino was it yeah
that's junior high when you saw that
happen were you like man he got himself
a white girl well so i read a lot about
that i read a lot about that and yeah
the after the the jealousy faded
did you guys know that
his friend would drive her car around
like a parking lot what cause you know
he's young he can't drive you around a
parking lot so they could do it in the
back seat
wait how old was his friend 14. i
imagined that by the same age should
have went to jail for sure
you're 12
13 14 it doesn't matter
and you're driving while your friend is
you know getting it on with like a hot
white girl or even if she's not hot yeah
she could be ugly
you are looking you are not driving
wherever you are
you are looking yeah but you have to
think like a kid right if you're
stationary in one spot
you can get caught moving target yeah
you can't get caught how you gonna get
me
yeah
that was her yeah she's pretty wow girl
next door right there so you know she
got pregnant from from the kid and then
on a conjugal she got pregnant again
i think they have like two or three kids
and then when he became what like 30 or
like late 20s early 30s he divorced her
whoa and i think i know why forget about
irreconcilable differences i'm sure
there's that because you know they
realize they not know each other they
don't like each other but now letourneau
is probably like 50. yeah yeah and he's
looking around going
wait a minute here or or he became 30
and was like yo i can't believe you let
me [ __ ] you in the back of your car
while my friend yeah yeah drove you
around that's pretty crazy already no no
he's like i need to [ __ ] a 20 year old
it's just not doing it for me
because you know and you know white
women don't age like asian women do how
how old was this yeah well white women
aged like almost like regularly asian
women old age like immediately after
like menopause yeah go downhill with a
steep drop yeah yeah but they look
really good in their 40s and stuff
almost yeah and then so you know that
kid was just like he cut some one day
and then that steep drop happened whoa
okay we got a divorce let's have an
honest conversation though as men
would you guys [ __ ] sarah palin because
i still think she's hot
i haven't seen a recent picture of her
when she was campaigning oh yeah oh so
you're not asking if we already did
did you [ __ ] sarah pal i cannot say i
did or did not
[Music]
hey that's cool though that's chill how
would you maybe [ __ ] her baby yeah
supposedly if you did how did i maybe
new style
she's the last i couldn't do korean
style what's crazy
she didn't deserve that
dude yeah she's attractive 100
she also has [ __ ] labia neck though
ladies on the fire like that
kind of works for her but you know
there's something about whether you okay
who who's like let's say marjorie taylor
green was like hot i haven't seen her
what'd she look like she she's the
congresswoman she's on vampire diaries
yeah super like anti-vaccine
anti-virus and also like what's
anti-virus is it everybody gets the
virus
and then like she's like you know she's
little too mildly to severely racist but
but let's say but let's say she's gonna
figure a scale for that yeah this one
right here let's say she's hot i'm sure
people find retracted but let's say
she's hot there's something about
sleeping with a celebrity though yeah
you're right you know what i mean like
yeah there's a lot that's why we're a
congresswoman a congresswoman there's a
power behind it and so like my guess is
because i feel like people in like that
part that position
they're they're getting some yeah
i'd sleep with them if they could hurry
up and help me with my um build for my
business because it's been taking too
long well you know the pages i mean they
don't even get to say whether they want
to [ __ ] or not most of the time that's
why they have a congressional slush fund
to pay for all the [ __ ] sexual abuse
allegations probably yeah yeah buddy i
mean because like look at these women in
congress or in power and i'm not saying
all of them so please don't think i'm
i'm like anti-feminist
which ones just like you know a couple
of them you know let's say like some of
them are lonely because their husbands
neglect them and the easiest access like
with clinton the easiest access was his
intern monica lewinsky that was easy
maybe he didn't want to like go through
all the hassle of getting people
whatever whatever the reasons are
but they're there yeah if they have like
an intern or a page or whatever they're
there and if they're willing
and for guys and girls yeah i can't
judge them it's so convenient because i
have way more power than them so it's
like you know if they say no like i can
destroy your life
fire them
your [ __ ] life
i heard in politics it was actually a
really like down low situation with a
lot of uh gay dudes
yeah yeah like they're they're in the
closet a lot of politicians are
enjoying life but but they're afraid to
come out yeah see monica was a yes every
time for me people made fun of for the
90s i remember jay leno and everybody
all the late night comics making fun of
her and stuff but she's not i think
there's something about that political
look where it's like and you ain't that
[ __ ] like tidy and stuff like come on
you were you a dirty girl
it's the fact that they probably
graduated from one of the top
universities and they're probably like
educated and well learned and you know
there's that going on oh yeah because
you're like [ __ ] prestigious things
yeah you know it's like it's like the
robin right [ __ ] you ever watched that
show what the [ __ ] is it called the
political one on netflix the one on
netflix that she was on with kevin
spacey's oh wow oh how's the car
[ __ ] fireball i was like
well in that show they're [ __ ] all
the time they're doing all kind of weird
creepy [ __ ] and yeah to what joe was
saying kevin spacey
speaking of child cares oh yeah
that's true kid diddler yeah and great
actors yeah and great actress he's
pretty good he's really pretty good hey
his uh when he when he got uh pretty
much cotton he had to admit it and he
gave that last uh video speech of him in
character
[ __ ] good dude creepy but good with
the southern accent yeah why did he do
that yeah yeah yeah was that necessary
does anyone know yet
because his i think to me his narcissism
is so huge yeah that he's just like you
know what he's like this will fix
everything
dude imagine thinking you're that tight
dude you're like dude i'm sick watch
this [ __ ]
it was it was kind of cool
he got anthony and he's on board
i was like why would you do this but
[ __ ] that's interesting i was like well
half of me was like is this a deep fake
like is this real like i can't believe
this is actually happening that was nuts
he's nuts didn't like some of his
accusers get killed or something like
that yes somebody so he made a weird
veiled threat in that video and then
people have taken it to like
of course of course people think people
take things like unnecessarily too far
they'll read into it you know it's all
those internet salutes it's like he's
telling me to do this like he's telling
me to kill somebody okay first of all
he's not but second of all even if he
was
why are you doing this
like like you're acting like he's jesus
or some [ __ ] ask john hinckley jr bro he
tried to shoot ronald reagan because
he's like jody foster wants me to murder
ronald reagan okay that's what's going
on that's what's going on you understand
he's right in his mind yeah he's like
i'm correct about this by the way she
told me through watching her so
that's all i know you see what you want
to see
and as independent as we like to believe
we are in america as americans like you
know that's why we we won't wear masks
because you can't tell me what to do but
yet if jodie foster tells you to do
something you got to do it but it's jody
foster johnny foster yeah that's like
that's like dave chappelle with the
whole bit like ja rule we need y'all
rule yeah right now what's y'all real
think about 9 11. [ __ ] joe ruth
that's america dude straight up i don't
give a [ __ ] about you yeah [ __ ]
president all right
tell me mariah carey how do you feel
about coleman right now back when on the
news they would bring them in onto the
news stories and ask them questions
see jody yeah but it wasn't this jody
foster though i think
it was super fudge jody foster
wasn't it like it looked like she was
even younger right yeah yeah yeah that's
crazy uh yeah
that's the thing is like okay if you're
a little nuts and you don't know you're
nuts and you hear voices and you hear
jodie foster tell you this okay that's
cool whatever you believe you know i
believe that's totally chill yeah i
believe that you believe it yeah but
then once they tell you to do something
where where do all your like you know
guards go where it's like no i'm not
gonna do that like you can't tell me
what to do yeah
jody okay
that's why i guess i'm a big fan that's
why i guess i'm so disappointed
sometimes when i hear things because you
remember when nancy kerrigan got taken
out with the pipe yeah yeah and like you
know
all tonya harding had to do was be like
yo jody foster [ __ ] told me
it's already baked into the cake
everyone's like dude jody fox was
telling people to do some [ __ ] up jody
foster's kind of [ __ ] up dude we
should cancel her yo you know at least
one news organization is going to be
like you know
maybe it is jody foster yeah you know
all you need is one someone's gonna run
with it there's gonna be a couple
articles you know i need jesse waters to
tell me about what's going on with jody
fox
[Music]
you